[Müzik]
Herkese merhaba Nasılsınız iyi misiniz
yorgunluk var mı Yok heyecanlı gözlerle
bakan bir kitle var harika Az önceki
şunu da bahsedilen o eğlence kısmı benim
üzerimde bayağı sorumluluk getiriyor O
yüzden çok emin olamadım ama bakalım
Evet
şimdi
bilinmeyen deyince benim aklıma
lovecraft geliyor özellikle Gotik ve
Gizem öyküleri ile bilinen Amerikalı
ünlü yazar edgare Allen puanın izinden
ilerleyerek bu konuda çok önemli
yayınlar ortaya koyan biri bu ve 1900'lü
yılların başında çok ünlü bir
makalesinde
bugünkü buluşmanın teması olan
bilinmeyeni bakın ne güzel anlatmış
İnsanlığın en eski ve en güçlü duygusu
korkudur en eski ve en güçlü korku türü
ise bilinmeyenden korkudur
ne çok Roman yazıldı ne çok film yapıldı
bu bilinmeyen üzerine
İnsanoğlu cam bir fanusun arkasından
kendisine ulaşamayacağını bilerek bazen
korkuyla bazen de hayretle izledi izledi
Çünkü kimse küresel tehditlerin
kendisini Bu kadar derinden
etkileyeceğini kestiremedi Biz bugün bu
bilinmeyeni biraz kestirmek için bir
araya geldik ama bilinmeyen deyince
Türkiye'de çok fazla yaygın değildir o
konu çünkü Türkiye'de Herkes her şeyi
bilir
mesela yıllar önce Mustafa Denizli
Fenerbahçe'nin teknik direktörlüğünü
yapıyor Çok önemli bir maçtı saha
kenarından takımını yönetmeye çalışıyor
orada görevli bir polis memuru da
Çünkü taktik veriyor ama bu konudaki en
önemli noktalardan biri şu buradaki
hocam kim olabilir
şimdi hocam
bu hücrelerin
dna'ları nasıl koruduğuna ilişkin dönen
dolapları Sen bilmiyorsun Efendim bu
bana söylense sıkıntı yok ama bakın kime
söylenmiş
hayatını DNA ile ilgili çalışmalara
adayan Türkiye'nin gururu Profesör
Doktor Aziz sancar'a söylenmiş
Dolayısıyla Biz bilinmeyen noktasında
Biraz önemli bir noktadayız e bilinmeyen
deyince Bizde herkes her şeyi bildiği
için hepimizin
1980'li yıllardan hatırladığı ünlü
karaktere dönelim Tanıdık geldi mi
Cevat kelle her daim her şeyi bilen
hazır gazeteci Efendim günümüzde pek çok
şey güncelliyorlar Maslow 2.0 diyorlar
herhalde cevap kellenin de güncellenmiş
hali böyle olurdu Ne dersiniz
E biz de günümüzde bilinmeyen üzerinden
İngilizce konuşmaya yabancı dil
öğrenmeye çalışıyoruz ki bugün bunun
üzerinden Türklerin yabancı dille
imtihanını konuşacağız yıllar önce o
zaman saçlarım var mesleğe yeni
başladığım bir dönemlerde ders
anlatıyorum Heyecanlı bir şekilde
çocukların İngilizce konuşmalarına
yardımcı olmaya çalışıyorum derslerden
biri bitti bir tane öğrenci Odama geldi
Ben de bu ürettim sohbet etmeye başladım
Hocam ben İngilizce konuşmak istiyorum
dedi
takdir edeceğiniz üzere Ben ne olduğunu
anlamadım evladım Ne yapıyorsun sen
dedim Hocam İngilizce konuşuyorum dedi
Dolayısıyla bu ve buna benzer durumlar
oluşmasın diye Geçenlerde şöyle bir
tweet attım ben dedim ki ne kadar erken
dil öğrenme süreci başlarsa o kadar
olumlu sonuçlara evrilebiliriz
Dolayısıyla Biz bunu atıyoruz Bu konuda
çalışmalar yapıyoruz amacımız dil
öğrenme sürecinin mümkün olduğu kadar
erken başlanmaz aşağı gelen pek çok
yorumdan bir tanesi şu
Bizim kendi ana dilimizdeki eksiklikleri
ya da diğer konuları düşünmeden kültürel
aktivitelere erişim entelektüel çevre
eksikliği düşünmeden dil öğrenmeye dair
erken yaşta başlamanın bir kıymeti
harbiyesi yok var Efendim Çünkü biz dil
öğretmenleri iki konuda çok sıkıntı
yaşıyoruz birincisi
Mesleğiniz neydi dil öğretmeniyim ya
hocam hangi soru geliyor neden yabancı
dil öğrenemiyoruz ve biz bütünü
yeniiyetimizde bu konuyu cevaplamaya
çalışıyoruz ikinci konu ise şu anda
gördüğünüz Biz dil öğrenmeye dair böyle
amaçlar Edinelim böyle Çabalar
gösterelim dediğimiz zaman bizim bu
konularda yeteri kadar bilmediğimizi ya
da yeteri kadar oraya odaklanmamız
gerektiğini düşünüyorlar Hayır Çünkü
yıllar önce
şu karikatürde Gördüğünüz üzere dil
öğrenmeye dair böyle ilginç detaylar
anlatılmış bunu bir meslektaşıma
anlatıyor
çocuklara İngilizce konuşabilsin diye
grup etkinlikleri yapıyor arkasından
sıraların arasında çocukların İngilizce
konuşup konuşmadıklarına dair gözlem
yapıyor
yanlarına gidip What are you guys doing
arkadaşlar ne yapıyorsunuz diye bir soru
soruyor çocuklardan biri hemen atılıp
diğer diskasting diyor
aranızda pek çoğunuzun anladığı üzere
Biz iğrençiz diyor Halbuki VR diskassing
demesi gerekiyor işte böyle olaylar çok
oluşmasın ve biz her zaman dil öğrenme
sürecini ciddi alalım diye tekrar o
tweete dönelim o tweetin altındaki
yorumlar
bizim sanki singapur'dan
estonya'dan finlandiya'dan geldiğimizi
Türkiye Eğitim sistemindeki bu konuları
çok fazla bilmediğimize yönelik bazı
cümleler var Efendim Ben hayatım boyunca
devlet okullarında okudum Dolayısıyla
teoriyle pratik arasındaki ilişkiyi
bilen ve bu dil öğrenme süreci konusunda
çalışmalar yapan biri olarak Aslında bu
ülkelerin ne kadar başarılı olduklarını
anlamak için pisa'ya bakmak gerekiyor
birisi nedir Bize 15 yaşındaki çocukları
3 temel bilgi ve beceri setleri
açısından inceleyelim okuryazarlık fen
bilimleri okuryazarlığı ve matematik
okuryazarlığı Az önce neden bu üç ülkeyi
söyledim Çünkü bu ülkeye yerlere
turistik amaçlar dışında bir de Eğitim
amaçlı giden büyük bir kitle vardı bu
ülkeler pisa'da başarılı
Peki yan taraftaki görsel neyi anlatıyor
O da benim alanımı anlatıyor İngilizce
yeterlilik endeksi dünyada 110 tane
ülkeyi İngilizce yeterlilikleri
açısından sıraya koyan bir endeks Yani
bir çeşit Pisa diyebiliriz İngilizce
eğitiminin pisası diyebiliriz Ben de
yıllardır Az önce sorulan soruya maruz
kalan biri olarak Hocam neden dil
öğrenemiyoruz şöyle bir araştırma yaptı
pizzada başarılı olan bu ülkelerin
İngilizce yeterlilik endeksindeki yerini
merak ettim
alanımla alakalı olduğu için okuma
becerilerini aldım ve yanına İngilizce
yeterlik endeksindeki yerine baktım
birinci olan ülkenin İngilizce
yeterlilik endeksinde de 3 olduğunu 4
olan ülkenin 22 olduğunu şeklinde
görüyorsunuz
Bir de kendi ülkemize bakalım
pisa'da 40 sıradayız İngilizce
yeterlilik endeksinde de çok daha iyi
bir yerde olmamız gerekiyor
geri kalan ülkeler ise aşağıdan yukarıya
doğru çıkıyor yani siz pisa'da okuduğunu
anlamada ve diğer alanlarda
başarılıysanız bu doğal olarak
İngilizceye de yansıyor yabancı dile de
yansıyor Dolayısıyla bunların ikisi
arasında çok temel anlamda bir
korelasyon buldum Peki konuşmamın adı
Türklerin yabancı dille imtihanıysa bu
geçmişte böyle miydi
1821 yılında tercüme odası ile başlayan
Türklerin dil öğrenme mücadelesi
1964 yılında Memurlara yönelik Dil
Eğitim kurslarının açılması ile devam
ediyor
1924 yılından sonra çalışmak sen Onur
duyduğum Gazi eğitim fakültesinin Gazi
Eğitim Enstitüsü olarak kurulduğunu
görüyoruz ve 1933 yılında
Yabancı Diller şubesi devreye giriyor ve
bütün bunların etkisiyle dil öğrenmeye
dair O dönemki gazete manşetlerinde
bakın neler var
ehemmiyet verilmesinden tutunda
ortamekte ve lisans derslerde lisana
önem verilmesine kadar pek çok önemli
unsur var bunların da devamında 1955
yılında Maarif Kolejleri hem yabancı dil
eğitiminde ve de genel eğitimde çok
büyük başarılara imza atıyor arkasından
1975 yılında Anadolu Liseleri karşımıza
çıkıyor eminim Bu salonda da Anadolu
liselerinde okuyup çok güzel dil öğrenme
heyecanları hareketleri yaşayan o konuda
başarılı hikayelere sahip insanlar
vardır Dolayısıyla Biz her zaman için
1821 yılından bu zamana kadar dil
öğrenme konusunda ne yazık istendik
durumda olamamışız bu konuda sıkıntılar
olmuş bu tarihsel araştırmayı yaparken
Türk sporunu önemli katkıları bulunan
Selim Sırrı tarcan'ın bir makalesine
rastgeldim 1938 yılında akşam
gazetesinde
Selim Sırrı Tarcan Danimarka'nın
başkenti kopenhag'da katıldığı bir
toplantıdan söz ediyor ve bu toplantıda
insanların kendi dilleri dışında pek çok
farklı dilde başarılı hikayeler başarılı
şekilde konuştuğundan bahsediyor e
Mademki 21 yüzyılda ana nokta bireysel
tutumlar O zaman biz bu müthiş insana
bakalım Çünkü 1800'lü yıllarda o zaman
için çok çarpıcı olan bir cümle etmiş
İyi bir yöntem kendi kendine öğrenmeyi
benimser demiş o halde Biz dil öğrenme
sürecindeki tarihsel süzgeçten sonra
gelin bireysel olarak neler yapabilirizi
konuşalım Birinci ve en önemli nokta
bilinçli pratik
5 tane temel öneriden oluşan bu noktanın
Bugünkü konuşmadan sonra sizin
hayatınızda sizin Konfor alanınızdan
sizi çıkarmaya yardımcı olmasına
amaçlıyorum ve bu çerçeveden hareketle
belki dili öğrenme sürecindeki bu
sıkıntıları yaşayan insanların makus
talihini değiştirmelerine katkıda
bulunabiliriz 100 kere kelimeleri
tahtaya yazıp onları anlamsız bir
şekilde konuşmak bilinçli pratik
değildir
bilinçli pratikten bahsetmişken Geçen
hafta İstanbul'daydım nasıl oldu
bilmiyorum Bir taksiye binebildim Bunu
başardım taksi şoförüne toplantının
gerçekleştiği Oteli
harfleri tek tek söylemek suretiyle
anlatmaya çalıştım ve y n a n d o an
taksi şoförünün içinden İngiltere Kralı
çıktı
wydam Grand Hotel dedi Demek ki bu
arkadaş bilinçli pratik sürecini hayata
geçirebilmiş Peki bilinçli ayarları
pratik sürecinin hayata geçiremezsek ne
olur havalimanında neden orada olduğumu
söylemeyeceğim bir şekilde kendimi kayıp
eşya bürosunda buldum oradaki arkadaşla
eşyamın gelmesini Beklerken sohbet
ediyoruz hayatındaki en başa en ilginç
olaylardan biri nedir dedim şunu söyledi
kocasını unutan bir hanımefendi kayıp
eşya bürosuna geldi dedi
bir daha söylüyorum kocasını kaybeden
bir hanımefendi kayıp eşya bürosuna
geldi E ne yaptın dedim ister istemez
çekçekli mi yoksa çekmeli mi diye sordum
Dedi ne sordun çekçekli mi çekmeli mi
Çünkü o bilinçli pratik yapmadığı için
yıllardır insanlar bavul kaybettiğinden
dolayı ona sordukları soruda Adamcağız
onu söylemiş Dolayısıyla bilinçli pratik
son derece önemlidir
ikincisi Ne dil öğrenmek
kişiselleştirmek Bundan daha önemli
kişisel bir neden olabilir mi
Düşünsenize kabile de yaşıyorsunuz diğer
kabiledeki biriyle evlenmek için o dili
öğrenmeniz gerekiyor Bu çileye bakabilir
misiniz ya da sizin hayatınızda origami
önemli ise origami ile ilgili çalışmalar
yapabilirsiniz motor sporları ile ilgili
metinler dinleme metinlerinden
yararlanabilirsiniz bir başka önemli
nokta amacı yönelik olmak amaca yönelik
olmaktan kasıt şu; Ben yabancı dil
öğrenmek istiyorum dünyadaki en anlamsız
amaçlardan biridir Ben yüksek lisans
yapmak için yabancı dil öğrenmek
istiyorum ben dizileri ana dilinde
izlemek için yabancı dil öğrenmek
istiyorum Bu amaçlar sizin her zaman
yardımcı olacak önemli noktalardır bugün
Sevgili Hocam Acar Balta işte bunun
üzerinde durduğu hatalar bizim
arkadaşımız dil öğrenme sürecinde
hatalardan doğru şekilde beslenmemiz
gerekir
ama bizde bir lobi var ne olduğunu
biliyor musunuz Elalem neden lobisi çok
tehlikelidir Siz kendinizi ifade etmeye
başladığınız an Elalem orada devreye
girer divel diyeceksin developmen
diyecek demeyeceksin der ve siz
hatalardan kaçmaya başlarsınız çizginin
dışındakiler isimli müthiş bir kitap var
bu kitapta pek çok farklı alanda
başarılı olan insanları incelemişler
hepsinin ortak özelliklerinden bir
tanesi şu;
hatalarıyla barışıklar Dolayısıyla biz
Rahmet sürecinde hatalarımızda başarılı
olalım disiplinli olmak 5 önemli nokta
Çünkü disiplinli olma hususunda Şunu
söyleyebilirim ben iki günde İngilizce
çalışayım sonra arkasından çalışmayayım
mı olmaz benim 1990'lı yıllarda
izlediğim müthiş bir film vardı
Esaretin Bedeli orada bir karakter var
endy difrain
hapishaneye kitap getirebilmek için
6 yıl boyunca her hafta mektup yazıyor
Bence disiplinli olmanın ete kemiğe
bürünmüş halidir dil öğrenme sürecinde
de sürekli bir biçimde disiplinli
olmamız gerekir Aksi takdirde başarılı
olamayız toparlayacak olursak
Türkiye'nin dil öğrenme serüvenine
baktığımız bu konuşmadan sonra kendi
Konfor alanınızdan çıkıp bu 5 tane adımı
hayatımıza geçirdiğimiz zaman geçmişte
var olan dil öğrenme süreçlerini daha
başarılı hikayelerle donatmamız Mümkün
çünkü herkes dili öğrenebilir ve ben
bunları yapmayacağım diyorsanız o zaman
size video getirdim Hadi bir 30 saniye
izleyelim
içtiğinizde İngilizce konuşmaya
başlayacağınız yeni bir hap üretildi
anında İngilizce konuşuyorsunuz Denemek
ister misiniz isterim
Hello hello how are you How are you
speak English don't speak English
You are Cola
handsome and sende handson işe yarıyor
mu hocam yarıyor gibi İngilizce biliyor
musunuz Evet şimdi biz Bugünkü
konuşmadan sonra bilim dışı noktalarla o
hapları içmeye devam mı edeceğiz yoksa
ulu önder Mustafa Kemal Atatürk'ün
Hayatta en hakiki mürşit ilimdir deyip O
yoldan mı devam edeceğiz Karar sizin
efendim Teşekkür ederim
[Müzik]